يعني الحين فيه هنا فساتين كثيرة ما شاء الله
كل هذه الفساتين تلبسها الناس ولا أنت تحطها للعرض
لا كلها تنلبس، كلها حقت زباين
ما أستفيد منها، كل الزباين يستلموها
يعني ما فيها مثلًا تسويق
لا ما فيها تسويق، يجي الزبون بعدين نخيّط له
يعني هذا يلبسه الناس؟
أيوه كله أسلمه للزباين
محمد أجمل أنصاري، أشتغل خيّاط
من خمس وثلاثين سنة موجود في السعودية في الرياض
أخيّط كل شيء، للزواج للأفراد لرمضان للعزايم
أنا موجود هنا من عمر ست عشرة سنة
الحين عمري واحد وخمسين سنة تقريبًا
كنت صغير حتى ما كان عندي شنب
هل عمل الخيّاط روتيني؟
كل يوم يختلف شغلنا وما يتكرّر
ممكن أرسم تصميم للزبون
أو يجيني التصميم من الزبون
أو يوريني الموديل بالجوال وأنا أخيّط مثله
وفيه زبون عنده الصورة جاهزة، ويقول لي عدّل وغيّر عليها
هنا مثال، هذا الزبون قال لي أخيطه
زبون ثاني طلب نفسه بس بلون فوشي
كيف يختلف العمل اليوم عن السابق؟
أول كنّا نستخدم في شغلنا المجلات
بعدين جت فترة منع المجلات في المحلات
ممنوع أي مجلة في المحل
ولو كانت مجلة موجودة، فالصور كانت تتغطى بالقلم الأسود
تخيّط عبايات؟
أيوه أخيّط عبايات
طيب إيش الفرق بين خياطتها زمان واليوم؟
كثير فيه فرق الحين
زمان غالبًا العباية تكون أسود سادة وتنلبس
الحين نخيط لها زخارف وكلف
الحين تلقى الملون والأسود
فوشي أسود أزرق
أغرب حادثة مرّت عليك
دخلت إبرة في يدي، وما عرفت لشهر كامل
رحت المستشفى وأعطوني علاج
بس كل ما سألوني قلت ما عرفت إن ظلت الإبرة شهر كامل
كلهم يقولون لي موجودة الإبرة، وأنا أقول ما فيه إبرة
أخذت العلاج لشهر بعدين عملت عملية
شافوها بالأشعة بعدين طلعوها
كيف علاقتك مع الزبائن؟
كل زبايني يرجعوا يجوني
عندي كثير زباين من خمس سنوات وعشر سنوات
وعندي زباين من خمس عشرة سنة
نفس الزبون؟
إيه نفس الزبون
حتى لو نقل من هنا وراح مكان ثاني، برضو يرجع
مثلًا فيه زبون قديم خيّطت له
كبرت بنته وتزوّجت وبرضو خيّط هنا، والله موجود
هل الخياطة أرخص من الملابس الجاهزة؟
لو الموديل موجود ومعروف وخفيف، ما فيه مشكلة يجي رخيص
لو الموديل معقد سعره يصير أغلى
فيه ناس تقول الأسعار تختلف من سنة لسنة، وإن اليوم تغيّر عن زمان
لا ما تختلف
الزبون ممكن يجي في رمضان في ليلة العيد
يكون السعر الأصلي مئة ريال، يقول لي بعطيك مئتين أو ثلاث مئة
أنا أقول لا
إيش الفايدة لما يجي موسم ارتفاع الأسعار
لكن الزباين تقول إني أخذت فلوس زيادة؟
ما ينفع
إيش الفرق في الأسعار بين سعرك في مشغلك ومشغل نسائي؟
فيه فرق كثير
مثلًا شيء أخيطه بثلاث مئة، عندهم ممكن بست مئة أو سبع مئة
عشان تعديل المقاسات، وعشان يتكلمون بالعربي مع الزبونة
كيف تستعد لموسم رمضان والعيد؟
لا ما نسكّر وناخذ إجازة
نشتغل كل يوم، ثلاثين يوم في رمضان
ونشتغل أربع وعشرين ساعة ليلة العيد رغم إننا لازم ننام
رمضان ممكن نشتغل ست عشرة ساعة، غالبًا في الليل عشان نصوم وكذا
لازم أخيّط، ولو جاني ليلة العيد مثلًا أو قبل بيوم، من المغرب أو العصر
يقول أبغاك تخيّط التنورة على خفيف كذا، فنخيّط له
حتى نسلّمها في ليلة العيد، الساعة ثلاثة أو اثنين في الليل
لو كان رمضان تسع وعشرين يوم مو ثلاثين
أوقّف شغل استلمته من قبل يوم يومين
عشان أعرف كيف بسويه وكم بيحتاج وقت، وفي أي وقت ممكن أخيطه
تصرفات تزعجك من الزبائن
كثير أشياء! أكثر شيء الزبون اللي دايم مستعجل
في وقت الإجازة، كل الزباين يحتاجوا الخياطة تخلص في يوم
لو اليوم جمعة، يقول لازم تخلص في يومين ثلاثة، وكل الزباين كذا
يتعب راسي من أي زبون مستعجل
صارت مشاكل مع زبون ممكن مرتين خلال الخمس وثلاثين سنة
مدري إيش مشكلة مزاج الزبون
تكون القطعة خلصت ثم يقول فيها مشكلة
أقول له بصلحها لك، يقول خلاص باخذها بدون ما أدفع
كثير الزباين اللي كذا
واحد مرة أخذ فلوسه مني بعدين ضربني والله
يضرب؟
إيه، والله حتى من الشباك كذا
إيش سويت له؟
متى ستتوقف عن الخياطة؟
الله كريم ويعرف متى أوقف
ما أعرف كم سنة بظل موجود بعد اليوم
أحس ممكن بعد سنتين أروح والله
وإذا ما رحت؟
الله كريم، لو ما رحت ببقى موجود بهالدنيا
خمس وثلاثين سنة ممكن يزيدوا
مرّات أقول لنفسي أنا اشتغلت خمس وثلاثين سنة
أشتغل طول الوقت، مخي خلّص
أوقف وأقول خلاص إيش أسوي هذا شغل
أفكر كثير بعائلتي وبأولادي
أحيانًا عائلتي يقولون لي خلاص اترك الشغل
وأنت إيش تقول؟
إن شاء الله
يعطيك ألف عافية
شكرًا
دقيقة باقي
اصفق بقوة
أقوى!
يعطيك العافية، شكرًا